these are the dramatic moments when a
crane collapsed while loading a
generator onto a ship the crew diving
into the water as it begins to flounder
after taking quick action to save
themselves work began to save the
delicate marine life around them
approximately 2000 litres of diesel was
in the Orca barge it's being handled in
a way to prevent a significant
environmental impact
Ecuador's government declared an
emergency after the incident on Sunday
and by Monday it said it was under
control we shouldn't be relaxed about
this it's not a minor issue if we hadn't
reacted as we did it could have been a
lot more serious the Galapagos Islands
are home to dozens of vulnerable species
found nowhere else in the world the
region's diversity helps inspire Charles
Darwin's theory of evolution after he
visited the islands more than 200 years
ago half of the reptile species here are
threatened or endangered marine iguana
species were decimated during a 2001 oil
spill that dumped hundreds of thousands
of litres of fuel into the ocean
scientists later discovered it killed
60% of marine iguanas on nearby Santa Fe
island early tests on animals nearby
show no visible signs of damage from
Sunday's spill but the government says
it's too early to see the impact on the
ecosystem this is one of the world's
most fragile ecosystems with threats
like climate change already an issue
more will have to be done to prevent
spills like this Andrew Chappell
al-jazeera